What do you do for recovery?
Do you fuck around with cryotherapy
or Saunas or nothing? Nothing, dude.
Nothing really. No. Nope.
Nothing. Uh, how come?
I don't know. I cause I haven't
really liked needed it. Yeah. Uh,
you should just get a sauna. Get us
all in your gym. Yup. Just that alone.
Get a sauna and a fucking
ice bath. Yeah. I drink,
I drink beer for recovery.
That's that.
That's an nightly ritual.
I will,
I will not be able to function
if I don't how many beers? Oh,
usually route four. But they're
like good quality pints. You know,
I'm not like Chug a lug in
Nascar soda by the case. Right.
Um,
barley pops,
but like good quality a IPA,
stouts,
porters or that kind of thing. You
just live for it. Yeah, I love it.
I'm a hobbyist and then ama
hobbies that are bourbon,
so I, that doesn't seem to go hand
in hand. A lot of people's eyes.
I know hard. You freaking kidding me.
It's like, hey man, I have a policy.
My wife having a, and I have a
policy every night is Saturday night,
but every morning is Monday
morning. Wow. I like it. Yeah.
So we'd go out almost every night we
go out just because if I'm at home,
I'm going to work.
I'm going to work until I fall asleep.
So you know, that clock hits six,
seven at night. I'm like, all right,
let me go meet my wife.
She's getting off of work.
We're going to go have a couple pints,
have a big old bourbon or
something like that. And uh, Yup.
I smoke cigars. Um, dip, uh,
how to, to kick. The thing is,
well that's what I'm going to diet.
It's all about diet.
I mean,
my Diet's ridiculous and it's
predominantly when I meal prep,
um, it's Collard Greens, Spinach,
bell pepper and chicken and that's it.
And then spice it up with, you know,
salt, pepper, garlic prep for the week.
You make like a bunch of,
but it doesn't,
I don't have a pot big enough to prep
for the week. So I prepped for like two,
three days at a whack and just chow down.
And that's the other thing.
Diet man die. You know, there's this,
what's due to puts a secret and diet,
eat food in food doesn't
come in a bag or a box.
That's a product shop at the
periphery of the grocery store.
If you go into the guts,
all you're going in there as for coffee,
all boils salt and that's it. Yeah. Um,
that's a good way of looking at you.
Stay right. Stay on the outside.
That's where the meat and vegetables,
Yep. Beware of the inside.
Just be aware if you're going in
there, go with a purpose. You know,
don't get a bunch of God
Damn
God. Yup. Because that,
and then the older you get,
the less you can prop your body can't
process that crap. Right? So Diet for me,
get in the morning. It's habitual for
quarter waters. Since I wake up full,
full quarter one, first thing, power
slam. Don't even don't even set it down.
And then, um, why is that?
What's the thought process
behind? I'm getting that down.
I'm getting it in me.
No waste in time.
It's there for a reason.
I want to cause you wake up dehydrated.
I just want a power slam that and uh,
get it all into me.
Um, and then, you know, a
clean it to clean breakfasts,
like a couple of boiled
eggs and some bacon.
And then throughout the day in people say,
well,
is there a certain amount? Because too
many people follow too many like diets,
which good for them if you're
following a diet, Kudos. Um,
but like meal times and how many times
a day I eat when I'm hungry and I don't
eat til I'm full. It's, it's
pretty freaking simple. Uh,
you don't eat until you're full, so right
back off, right when you hit like 70%,
80% about that,
about that.
And then part a portion
of that is thinking, well,
what if I got a sprint 400 yards?
You know,
or what if I got a kick somebody's ass
right now, right now. And if I'm 100%,
I mean it's going to be
shooting out of both ends. Um,
so I die is freaking huge man.
Huge.
But it allows me to drink
those beers at night. You know,
it allows me to do stuff like that and
then make sure I'm hitting it every day.
That, uh, you know, the gym,
even if on the road, um,
I usually don't have time
for seven days. Um, and I,
even if I did,
I probably wouldn't,
I'd probably take at least
one day off maybe too. Um,
but you know,
as well as I do that you are more in
tuned when you get older to what your
body's telling your brain, your body
when you get older, says, you know what?
Back the fuck off today.
You don't need to do this shit.
And I listened to that man.
I do listen to them.